what's up guys
bang bang it's lunch money time well
while she's trying to get rich the rest
of us just trying to get our lunch money
right
i'm here with polina we back we back
home
that's right let's go uh don't forget
that lunch money is now sponsored by
block five
go get a block by account you can
deposit crypto and earn up to eight
point six percent apy in an interest
bearing account
duh no brainer you can buy and sell
crypto or you can
get a us dollar loan and get your crypto
collateral go get a block by account
blockfit.com go
get an account all right plano doesn't
think we can do this in eight minutes
today's gonna be a lightning speed
around ready set
it's raining outside and it's dark and
then the quality is bad and i'm just
upset but it's okay
okay so it is raining very hard there's
zero light
um because god's crying for all the
bitcoin bears
guys first topic is bitcoin bitcoin is
flirting
with twenty thousand um it keeps going
up and down
on nineteen thousand seven hundred but
what i witnessed this morning
is a dance you have never seen before
a dance so aggressive i was like oh no
calm down it's called the bitcoin dance
i was dancing on graves that's what i
was doing i was dancing on graves
that's all you got to know all those
bears i had my receipts typed out i was
ready to let it fly
and pelina yelled at me and told me to
delete my tweet she said do not tweet
that that is
inconsiderate i said and i said and i
said
well tell the bears they shouldn't have
been bears
because they're wrong bitcoin is at 19
700 or so when we're recording this bang
bang what's up
i told y'all by the way when it breaks
20k
get your seatbelt on keep your arms and
legs within the vehicle
are you going to dance for liftoff oh
i'm dancing on grapes
let one of these idiots tweet at me
today you show your dance no let one of
these idiots tweet at me today all right
and by the way they're not gonna say
anything they're all gonna be real quiet
go ahead right
sorry i had to take two minutes to rant
r.i.p
salesforce which has been one of tech's
biggest acquirer in recent years
has been in talks to buy slack slack the
the tool we use
every day to communicate with teammates
partners
people in our community our company um
are you okay i'm fine uh so slack shares
surged
almost 38 after the initial report wow
yeah this is a no-brainer i mean how
much would they have to buy well
if your sales force well the market cap
is 23 billion so at least 23 billion
well like a lot more though
maybe because the multiple i know all
about a multiple no the market cap is
the multiple of the revenue
it's okay i don't get public markets
okay go on that's just the valuation of
any company and i know but like
valuation market cap like i i get the
private part okay go on
no i got it market cap is valuation
evaluation is i know ah
she does that all right so if a sales
force and you want to sell
software to the enterprise customer so
basically things to help you do work
wouldn't it be great to also own the
thing where they're all sitting and
talking
about work at work duh this makes a lot
of sense
uh mark benning benioff in salesforce
have been acquiring lots of companies
it would be very interesting to see how
much of it is cash versus stock
pelina's laughing because she's been
doing this stupid-ass puzzle on this
table
for he's missing him a gazillion years i
i'm gonna just say this right now
puzzles are stupid puzzles are stupid
you know why they're stupid because you
waste a bunch of time doing things that
are not productive it's meditative
that's fine i asked him to help me last
night to find
corners like the easiest thing in the
world and he was like oh oh
i don't know how to do this i gotta go
this is confusing me
yeah like what she's like find purple
corners no i don't got time for this i
got another [ __ ]
all right next food puzzles suck puzzles
are awesome
food delivery app doordash is looking to
raise up to 2.8 billion in its ipo which
would value the company at 32 billion on
a
fully diluted basis i think that they'll
get this
yeah why not food delivery's hot they're
hot
they're growing many markets they're the
leader makes sense 2.8 billion i'd love
to know what they're gonna do with the
money i'll look later
next under armor announced monday the
launch of the curry brand with
uh nba star steph curry a long time
under armour
athlete in a bid to reach younger
consumers and compete with nike and his
jordan brand i feel like
every year there's somebody trying to
compete with nike and his jordan brand
and somehow they always felt fall flat
do you know why
why do you know why why
because stephen curry ain't michael
jordan it ain't that hard
he's not michael jordan so yes right
strategy
wrong player guess what people love
steph curry of course but he's not
michael jordan
he's good he's really good he's one of
the top 10 players in the nba right now
but he's still not michael jordan the
only two players in
history that are even in the
conversation lebron and kobe
wait is lebron does lebron have a brand
of course
oh does he but he's got like the lebron
james
shoeland right and it's like one two
three whatever what they're trying to do
here is like make it a whole
thing and they did it with the rocks we
will forget the rocks collection
uh with under armour has been somewhat
successful pretty successful they sell
out of a lot of stuff things like that
but at the same time the rock ain't
trying to compete with michael jordan
the rock is owning
the rock is the original in his sector
stephen curry is on the court an amazing
player
when it comes to apparel sales ain't
nobody know who this guy is
really well they know who steph curry is
but from a sales perspective
how are you ever going to compete with
jordan jordan is a brand that is
ingrained into
culture you walk down the street and you
see michael jordan's shoes on somebody's
feet
you're like damn they get it you see
steph curry's shoes on somebody's feet
and you're like yo are those the paul
george's or are those the steph curry's
you don't even know paul george's um all
right
black shout out to nba fans you got that
joke go ahead
is paul george a singer no no
i think that was george michael i'm
thinking of okay so black definitely
doesn't have a shoe
black friday he passed away don't speak
ill of the dead
uh black friday hit a new record with
consumers spending 9 billion an increase
of 21.6
year-over-year it was the second largest
online spending day i participated
in us history coming in behind cyber
monday 2019.
wow wow it was still down
from last year though yeah they say all
that stuff don't let them trick you wait
online sales were down were they well
that's what you just said
no i didn't cyber monday 2019 was the
biggest day
ever black friday 2020
is the second biggest so the online shop
nobody but
black friday was bigger than the black
friday of last year of course right
but it's still from 2019 to 2020. it's
down a little bit but
cyber money is today and so my guess is
that this cyber monday will be bigger
than last cyber monday so we'll get the
bigger print it's fine
they're trying to trick people ain't
nobody going to the stores though less
than two billion dollars was spent in
the stores
okay ask lunch money next we have one
minute let's go
ask lunch money time because i got a i
got a call i got to get on okay we do
not care about your girl i've missed the
people
i need my time you're wasting people
okay uh
s asks thoughts on what to do when you
have many projects already content
creation mostly
but are thinking of starting new ones
and time is getting in the way of it
also whether to do them in spanish or
english is i fully grasp both languages
thank you so this is a time management
question and i always think like
don't start new projects that are going
to just
divide your attention and make both
things shitty instead of
one thing amazing i agree do it in
english if you have a full grasp of both
languages
english is much more pervasive on the
internet versus spanish
uh but there's something to be said
about uh
like penetrating new markets
sure where there aren't a lot of you
know spanish speaking newsletters
it's just if you're optimizing for the
largest thing possible
english language is always going to be
better you can always add spanish later
it's usually harder to go from a spanish
brand to an english brand than it is
from an english brand to a spanish brand
the other thing is on time management
you might not like this advice but make
time that's true
make time audit your time you're
probably wasting time doing dumb stuff
i waste a lot of time i waste a lot of
time and every time i audit my time i'm
like damn i'm wasting a lot of time i
got to stop doing that wasteful stuff
and focus on more
uh valuable productive stuff so if i
have to do that
you for sure are wasting time look at
your time what are you wasting time on
stop doing that and go focus on this
stuff
okay god you do have so much time if you
don't play on twitter
um yeah but i'm popping interactive
ledger 100 million impressions of monks
go ahead come on hurry yeah we're late
um question to pimp will you run for
president
well i would love to but i can't because
i wasn't born in the united states even
though
i am a citizen they don't let
naturalized citizens
become president are you flexing on us
that you're a citizen flexin
yeah did you pass a citizenship test i
don't think so i didn't either because
my parents did and i automatically got
it but if i was to pass
i would you couldn't pass the test oh my
god okay you know the pledge of
allegiance yes
do you know how to sing the national
anthem okay you don't have to sing the
national anthem why not
go ahead i don't want to hear that
question for pomp
can you briefly explain okay guys this
question comes up
a lot listen carefully so i don't have
to do it again
can you briefly explain the risks
associated with block fi how does
rehypothecation
re-hypothesis work in crypto
specifically in block fight in the case
where block fights hot or cold wallet
gets hacked
how will the losses be socialized
between all users like how bitfinex
implemented
the 36 haircut how will block fight deal
with the wallets getting hacked go
block fight doesn't hold your crypto
block fire has a custodian which is
gemini
gemini hold your crypto block fight
doesn't hold your krypto what block
fight does do though is it
rehypothecates
only in the interest bearing account i
believe uh and what they do there is
you give them crypto they take some or
all of your crypto
they lend it out to other people you
then they're paid
interest and they give you a percentage
of that interest that they're paid
now this is exactly what your bank does
so rehypothecation is actually something
that banks do
when you give your dollar to the bank
it's not your dollar anymore they take
your dollar
and they lend it out to people sometimes
they lend it out multiple times
they get paid let's say three percent on
that they turn around and they give you
three basis points so 0.03 percent
but they're earning 3.00 so they keep
majority at the bank
you get a small little piece in your uh
account
what the risk is in both of those
scenarios is that the person they're
lending the money to
ends up not being able to pay it back
now in
certain uh scenarios so banks for
example have fdic insurance right so
up to 250 thousand dollars you're going
250 000 you're not insured
in crypto the crypto usually is not
insured
but there's insurance uh that gemini has
right it's not necessarily on the
lending capability but if there is some
sort of
loss in terms of a hack or something
like that then there is this captive
insurance
super complicated i don't want to try to
explain it in literally 30 seconds
uh what i would search for is just
google gemini captive insurance
and you'll be able to learn all about
the insurance that they've set up there
and then the key piece is that block fi
does not hold your crypto
gemini holds it and block fight is
simply doing the lending
but the difference between your bank and
block fi is block fight does not keep
majority of the money that they earn
from the loan instead they deliver it to
you that's how they're able to pay such
high interest rates like 8.6 percent apy
etc is because they're actually just
giving tons of that
interest back to you rather than keep it
for themselves sound good
great awesome guys i appreciate it i
appreciate all of you
by the way bang bang bitcoin all-time
high toldja
see ya bang bang hope you guys enjoyed
this episode of lunch money as much as
we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block five is my second favorite thing
in the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to eight point six percent
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange i personally
use the interest bearing account
there's not very many places where
you'll find up to eight point six
percent
interest on a deposit in an interest
bearing account go do your own research
there's risk associated but eight point
six percent is pretty compelling
so click on the link in the description
say thanks to the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends